epic games has [ __ ] up fortnite
esports beyond repair
thanks for watching no wait actually
wait wait there's more to this
[Music]
so over the last few months it's become
clear that epic has no idea what they're
doing with fortnite esports or
at the very least that they don't care
let's go all the way back to may 2018
when epic games put 100 million dollars
into fortnite esports it was pretty
clear right then and there there was a
chance to do something enormous with the
game's esports scene
it was quickly becoming the biggest game
in the world but a successful esports
scene would have been really important
to the longevity of a game in what was
then an
uncertain time over the months that
followed though it became clear that
epic's competitive dreams for fortnite
weren't gonna work out
i think the lag stopped right now no no
i'm warping all over the world oh
everywhere i can't switch my gun my gun
won't switch 250
000 tournament pogs
here's a small list of problems the game
has for a long time fortnite lacked any
way to play private custom games with
other top players in fact
top players used to just gather in a
discord and i'll hit the play button the
same time
hoping they'd all end up in the same
server
these days fortnite does have the arena
mode which does let top players play
against good players with matchmaking
but
it doesn't solve all the problems next
came the cheating
recently epic banned over a thousand
players who competed in their first
online world cup
open and they revoked cash prizes for
200 of those players
cheating in fortnite tournaments can
take a lot of forms there's the actual
cheating software of course but there's
also teaming up in solos
playing on multiple accounts for
multiple regions and of course stream
sniping
i'm just gonna wait for him to finish it
let's do a screenshot right there
stream sniping is an issue that really
[ __ ] with the best players in the world
plenty of people have been banned for it
but it's extremely difficult to police
and the top players don't really have
any choice
but to make themselves vulnerable to it
a lot of these pros make most of their
money from streaming that means that
not streaming online tournaments is bad
for their bottom line
but that also means that stream snipers
get to have a field day with them
lasers watch for the email watch the
email
building there's emo there it is dude
stream sniping but all of this just
pales in comparison to the biggest slap
in the face epic continues to hand their
competitive scene
the patches it's happened over and over
again fortnite keeps getting huge
game-changing patches right before
tournaments think back to the infinity
blade
because he's creating so much carnage he
screamed so much
he got another one bissell the affinity
blade is too
good it's so powerful or epic's recent
changes to kill rewards that avengers
patch that's dropping soon
we have no idea what's in it but neither
do the pros
and they're the ones who have to win to
pay their bills not every change is game
breaking but
any change especially in this game where
it's hard to get practice with good
players
is a lot especially before a big
tournament the overall
frustration with epic's lack of care for
fortnite's competitive ecosystem
has led a lot of top players to just
focus on streaming instead of competing
this is my last competitive [ __ ] as a
world cup
i could definitely [ __ ] do well in it
but i'd rather
stream and do bad than not stream you
know
the fact of the matter is these players
make most of their money from streaming
anyway
online tournaments are fine but lan
events the ones where you're guaranteed
to play other players of your caliber
you have to leave your house for days at
a time to do them and the opportunity
cost of doing that
is just not worth it i would have to cut
my stream hours in half by and practice
twice as much as i normally do i would
be spending so much time
traveling to events and spending time
away from my wife and my family
when i already have so many activities
and events that i'm going to be doing
for for sponsors and partners and
there's so many other ways
dude that i'm going to be involved in
the community now let's jump back in
time again what if epic games took that
100 million dollars and instead
invested in a series of online
qualifiers that led to monthly lan
events at a studio somewhere that
featured the best players in the world
what if we got
what the pub g league has basically
already done listen i
know they're not the biggest success in
the world but logistically
they have figured out how to do battle
royale esports on a lan
they've gotten the best players in the
world playing each other which in theory
makes for the best competition and the
best story lines i think if that
happened
we wouldn't be in this mess to begin
with if tifu and quoxie and myth and
daequan were playing on a land every
month and able to stream from the studio
four knight esports would be [ __ ]
huge instead we're here
where some of those guys barely even
want to play tournaments
this tournament sucks dude there are
games you've never even heard of that
are esports
farming simulator is an esport because
people play it competitively for money
oh he's
wow 20 bales on the trailer here and all
my years of calling games are nothing
i've ever been this excited
you're excited feel these nipples i
am not a big fortnite fan myself but the
game's fine
the issue here is that epic had a chance
to turn it into a juggernaut in the
esports scene
and they [ __ ] it up at every turn
here's the thing though none of this
really matters
at this point i don't think fortnite
needs an esports scene and i don't think
epic should keep trying
sure it's nice that some players win
cash prizes from a couple events but
that doesn't make it a sustainable
ecosystem esports doesn't really seem to
matter to fortnite or epic and honestly
that's just fine not everything has to
have some massive esports scene
something can just be a fun competitive
game that people enjoy playing
look the point is if you're gonna do
esports do esports all the way
don't half-ass it like this thanks for
watching
if you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button